holiday music wouldn't be the same
without bells and neither would the
season itself despite the massive
technological change the world has
experienced the art of bell making and
bell ringing remains much as it has for
hundreds even thousands of years we met
up with some of those keeping this
ancient art alive
[Music]
[Applause]
for more than a century the striking of
clappers against the side of these
bronze bells
has been ringing vibrations across upper
montclair new jersey
oftentimes churches don't have real
bells in their bell tower
[Applause]
sean price is the director of music
ministries at st james episcopal church
so it's very special to me to have
actual real bells playing all the time
this has to be different yeah it's truly
a hands-on approach
price is a classically trained
harpsichordist but to learn how to
tickle these keys he had to take his
training up to a whole new level there's
a console set up on the second floor of
the tower
[Music]
where i'm pushing a lever that's
attached to a cord
that's then attached to a pulley system
that moves the clapper that hits the
side of the belt
that intricate system which feeds the 11
bells above
[Applause]
needed to be repaired
and it's no wonder the bells have been
in use ever since they were installed by
the mcshane bell company the bells were
cast in 1918
when james andrew acquired the mcshane
foundry he took possession of the
company's ledgers that date back to
1870. the interesting thing is these
bells were actually shipped via b o
railroad some will say canal so if they
went on the erie canal or by boat
unfortunately we don't know
how much they cost and some of the
original ledgers do show
what each bell was charged for
one
float i used to tell people that if my
wife and i both rode harley-davidson's
that would cost more than what i had in
my bell collection
[Applause]
still neil geppinger says he's spent
tens of thousands of dollars amassing a
collection of bells big
and small
as his collection of bells grew so did
his interest in their history geppinger
catalogued his vast collection in a
self-published book large bells of
america a history of bells and the
foundries that made them
he traces the earliest foundries in
america to paul revere who used bronze
recycled from cannons to make bells
after the revolutionary war
geppinger still owns one of revere's
bells
it's one of just a few he's holding onto
my favorite bell of my collection from
the standpoint of the sound is a 39 inch
diameter machine it's just got a
gorgeous tone
they cast their bells just a little
thicker than their competitors did
music to the ears of james android
so is this a disappearing art form then
casting bells while it is a disappearing
art form i don't think it will fully go
away i think there will still be the
need for bells and the want for that and
the beauty of it
[Music]
there are certain sounds that bring
people back to a time in their life that
may seem a little
happier perhaps especially during the
pandemic this music has really inspired
people
[Applause]
[Music]
it's given people hope
and it's given people something to
listen to and look out for every day
[Music]